hi I'm Max Keiser this is the Kaiser
report the show that goes further today
see max you know on our show we have
been saying for many years you can't
taper a Ponzi and of course the United
States Federal Reserve Bank is trying to
taper the Ponzi by unwinding
quantitative easing and raising interest
rates and we have seen the unwinding in
emerging market currencies and another
thing we've always said is that while
inflation is a monetary event that a
hyperinflation is a political thing is
when people lose confidence and the
political powers that be and you see
that in Venezuela but you're also
starting to see that in Argentina where
you're having almost hyper inflationary
like sort of movements in their currency
so I'm gonna look at something else that
we have been right about and that is
fracking and this is also part of that
whole Federal Reserve 0% interest rate
thing but the next financial crisis
lurks underground its name fracking
fueled by debt and years of easy credit
America's energy boom is on shaky
footing this is a headline actually from
the New York Times Bethany McLean the
one who outed Enron and warned before
they collapse but this chart is quite
interesting because here is when you and
I began warning about fracking and this
is US oil production so this is about
when a fracking really started to take
off at when interest rates were taken to
zero so the Green Line is the US oil
production yellow line is Russia oil
production mmm Amma's me of that phrase
peak everything Peak gas through
fracking peak credit via the central
bank system peak everything now the
remarkable thing that you and I we have
said this for years since the first
episode I could find was back in 2009 or
10 that we covered fracking and how that
that it cost more than they extracted in
value and we got reported by the DNI
report in front of the Congress as this
is somehow anti-american that this the
fact that we've pointed this out but now
this
the New York Times is and retweeted and
pushed also bite Paul Krugman so we're
gonna go into some of the details that
they're now coming around to in 2018
that you and I were saying you know
seven years ago eight years ago as well
and warning people about this but Summa
fracking's biggest skeptics are actually
on wall street bethany mclean points out
the sixty biggest exploration and
production firms are not generating
enough cash from their operations to
cover their operating and capital
expenses in aggregate from mid 2012 to
mid 2017 they had negative free cash
flow of nine billion dollars per quarter
a key reason for the terrible financial
results is that fracked oil wells show a
steep decline rate this is something
that you and i have pointed out the red
queen syndrome there's a huge steep
decline rate and you have to keep on
tracking fracking fracking many people
in the comments would say oh you know
this is just propaganda the DNI report
did also say that as well but here I'm
gonna read you some actual data from the
Kansas City Federal Reserve as part of
the US Federal Reserve System and they
say the amount of oil they produce in
the second year of a fracked well is
drastically smaller than the amount
produced in the first according to an
economist at the Kansas City Federal
Reserve production and the average well
in the back end a key area for fracking
shale in North Dakota declines 69
percent in his first year and more than
85 percent in his first three years a
conventional well might decline by 10
percent a year for fracking operations
to keep growing they need huge
investments each and every year to
offset the decline from the previous
year as well well this is gonna require
a massive bailout so in other words in
2008 the banks over lended and they got
bailed out the creditors got bailed out
here the frackers over fracked and with
too much borrowed money and they're
gonna need a massive bailout they'll be
considered systemically important
they'll be considered an industry that
we can't let go under especially since
we are in bitter
Lock competition with the other gas
producers of the world and they will get
a massive bailout it'll be probably the
excuse for a quantitative for a QE four
will be ushered in with this bailout
this will be the reason for four that
Bethany McLean now in the New York Times
seven years after you and I pointed this
out is now saying that the Federal
Reserve is responsible for the fracking
boom this is her exact quote because the
industry has such a voracious need for
capital and capital cost money
fracking could not have taken off so
dramatically were it not for a record
low interest rates after the 2008
financial crisis in other words the
Federal Reserve is responsible for the
fracking boom so they drove interest
rates down to 0% to bailout the
creditors of the whole subprime
financial system and all the fraud to
cover up all that fraud that went global
and was in pension funds and municipal
funds all over the world so they drove
rates to zero to try to bail out the
creditors and now what that did was at
0% interest rates we have a baby boom
population that was also beginning to
retire soon after the 2008 financial
crisis and their pensions were being
paid out and pension funds needed to
look for yield wherever they they could
find it and it was their investments in
private equity and hedge funds which
mostly has funded this cheap this easy
money to the frackers because they're
paying a yield which is much higher than
0% Amir Azir a fellow at the Columbia
University Center on global energy
policy calculated that the industry's
net debt in 2015 was 200 billion dollars
a 300% increase from 2005 but interest
expense increased that half the rate
that did because interest rates kept
falling dr. Azhar recently called the
post 2008 era of super low interest
rates the real catalyst of the shale
revolution and you know by the way there
has been an amazing you know
developments in the efficiency they are
able to extract oil and gas
oil and gas at a much cheaper price than
they used to be able to but the fact is
that interest rates are now starting to
rise so you know it with they're in a
race against time look you know what's
the difference between a conspiracy and
a conspiracy theory okay
so what's being described there by the
New York Times the role of the central
bank in the fracking industry is clearly
a conspiracy you have a conspiracy going
on between Wall Street and the energy
companies to create a fake energy boom
on unsustainable debt that's a
conspiracy now when we reported this
five six years ago and gave the exact
same reasonings that the New York Times
is giving today it was called a
conspiracy theory all conspiracies begin
as a theory it's called investigative
journalism investigative journalism is a
theory about a conspiracy and if it
proves to be correct as we were in this
case it's just a conspiracy the New York
Times will get a Pulitzer Prize for
reporting on this what piggybacking on
our work for the past five or six years
as they normally do now what we did
always look at what Wall Street was
saying and Wall Street was noting that
the absence of profits on the actual of
you know wells
so they however continue to make money
from the pension funds we kept on
lending giving them the money to give to
these frakkers so it's been you know
everybody's been happy because of the
whole Red Queen syndrome the the debt
had a natural need to keep on recycling
recycling and and and spinning and
spinning and spinning so if companies
however were forced to live within the
cash flow they produce these are the
words of the New York Times American oil
would not be a factor and the rest of
the world an investor told me this is
what we said you know many nations have
government spending policies they send a
man to the moon as a matter of national
security or national interest the fact
that they're pretending that this is
somehow like not some sort of policy
that benefits the nation
in terms of oil sort of wars that's
another thing and you know but here in
investors telling the New York Times
American oil would not be a factor on
the rest of the world if it were not for
zero percent interest rates well they're
finding geopolitical battles with debt
and they're throwing money at these
problems and the other countries that
they're fighting against Russia China
Iran are taking now that fiat money
being thrown at them they're buying gold
eventually when they the fan hits the
the problem you know the gold will went
out as it always does the other thing is
the New York Times and this piece
believes that it'll cause the next
financial crisis but I don't think
directly that debt well because there's
only two hundred three hundred billion
dollars compared to the trillions of
dollars that was a subprime mortgage
debt and that had been packaged up and
sold to people all over the world these
are debts that won't be able to repaid
clearly but they're held in pension
funds and pensioners and the America are
not getting their money anyway -
everybody knows it's all that Ashim but
I think the knock-on effect if these
companies do go bust then that oil
production that I showed you in the
first the chart because remember this is
how much oil the US produced from the
80s all the way up to 2008 when it took
off when fracking was possible but when
oil prices do rise if those debts full
you know are unable to roll over then
then of course you could have a
financial you're gonna have a contagion
remember Lehman Brothers was only 70 or
80 billion dollars but it caused a multi
hundred trillion dollar collapse so I
also wanted to turn to these tweets from
Paul Krugman because Paul Krugman is one
of these Russia Gators and and sort of
conspiracy theorists that's pushing all
these conspiracy theories and here he is
here's a tweet stream from the reporter
who uncovered the truth about Enron why
the fracking boom is a debt sustained
bubble headed for grief although not as
the headline suggests a likely cause of
the financial crisis - it's worth
pointing out though fracking has
received an incredible amount of hype
especially from people who explicitly
elevated its importance
as compared with renewables hello watch
years of Kaiser eport where we said
exactly that that it was actually
cheaper for solar wind and a
hydroelectric power than even fracking
and without causing all the ecological
devastation we're not even talked about
that all the carcinogens and water uses
your stuff and now fracking is in
trouble while renewables just keep
getting stronger but I guess some people
have a hard time taking hippie-dippie
energy sources seriously we are not
hippie-dippie energy sources but we've
been looking at what Wall Street was
saying and what the actual data number
showed and the return on investment
return on energy and the fracking sector
Paul Krugman or Tom Friedman and other
columnist over there at the Times they
have great grammar and good punctuation
but their content is worthless I might
also point out that Paul Krugman in 2008
was calling for an alien invasion in
order to get people to work at least
this is the equivalent of an alien
invasion it doesn't make any sense but
you're throwing money into a pit and
that's the way you'd love it why does it
though this is Keynesian you freaking
idiot you should be loving this oh let's
try you're completely inconsistent you
just go with the flow like a dead fish
in the river of Lies the newspaper you
work for the New York Times thanks Paul
freakin ridiculous strugglin well we got
to take a break here and contemplate all
this genius content you've been
spoon-fed from maxsa Stacey for years
making you the smartest person at any
cocktail party you've ever been to so
don't go away because there's gonna be a
lot more genius coming your way right
after the break
[Music]
welcome back to the constant report on
Max Keiser time now to turn to Wolfe
Richter of Wolfe Street dot-com Wolfe
welcome back thanks for having me back
Mike max alright let's talk about
Argentina and they issued a 100 year
bond recently it promptly started
selling off it looks like it's a
absolute junk what's the update well
like many emerging markets Argentina has
trouble borrowing in its own currency
cheaply because it continues to destroy
its own currency and so it borrows in a
foreign currency and a year ago little
over a year ago it was able to sell all
kinds of bonds denominated in u.s.
dollars and some other currencies and
one of those bond issues was a century
bond asunder Deobandi mentioned you know
Argentina defaulted on its foreign
currency debt about six times in the
last six decades or so so on average you
know you'll get a default on its foreign
currency debt about once every 10 years
and then 100 year bond you know he can
figure out how many defaults that will
be before the bond matures so people
bought that bond because at the time you
know interest rates were really low in
Europe that were it close to zero and
that bond offered a pretty good yield
and so people investors institutional
investors particularly decide okay we're
going to chase this yield we're going to
buy this bond and at this yield you know
surely the IMF will step in to to
guarantee the bond and in which the IMF
s at a history of doing and so we had
other bonds out there near that
Argentina's currency has punched by you
know in two days last week 25 percent
you know and about 50 percent so far
this year it becomes very difficult for
our agent inna to service its foreign
currency debt and that foreign currency
debt it now has been sort of guaranteed
by the IMF with a 50 billion dollar
bailout package but the Central Bank of
Argentina is blowing this money selling
dollars and buying pesos to support its
currency so this doesn't bode well for
those bonds well you know wolf Argentina
is never coming back for some basic
mathematical reasons you know back in
their early 1980s under George HW Bush
and the players on Wall Street like
Citibank Argentina was loaded up with a
lot of debt that they couldn't possibly
pay back minim who was leading the
country at that time turned out to be
completely corrupted in the pocket of
Wall Street the central banker of that
time caballo had all of his Washington
Consensus led theories about how to run
an economy they sold off over 200 state
assets the utilities the airport they've
got no income producing assets
whatsoever in Argentina is is dead
there's no economy there ever to support
a 100 year bond is like saying we were a
zombie we're dead we're never coming
back but it's beautiful wolf because
this is the original Greece the original
brexit the original country committing
financial suicide and it's back it is
beautiful and it's Argentina and it's
corrupting the global economy again
along with Turkey and all these other
basket cases well this is fantastic it
brings me right back to the early 1980s
in the beginning of my career this
beautiful wolf yeah I mean it's funny
how these things repeat themselves but
you have to remember who allows these
things to repeat themselves those of
foreign investors those investors that
are buying this Argentinian bonds in
Argentina now has 120 billion dollars in
in dollar-denominated debt out there you
know the two sides to this trade the
other side is the bias of these bonds in
my old rule is you don't ever lend money
in a foreign currency to the government
of Argentina you just don't
and the Argentina's don't trust her own
currency it's getting crushed you know
forever it was picked to the dollar with
a peso equals $1 back in four
2001 then the case though was let's
float and so now the peso is worth about
two point five cents eighteen years
later this is how Argentina does it you
know and and it constantly defaults in
its own currency through that way at the
same time you know you can't do that
with foreign currency but there are
constantly new investors out there that
chase that yield and the babys
Argentinian bonds and they make this
possible they're the enablers in this
and you know they're not listening to me
they're not realizing that you know
these bonds are kind of get defaulted on
yeah okay but Argentina is an occupied
country it's occupied by corrupt wall
street bankers has been for almost 40
years and the US media likes to say oh
it's socialism that's kids killing
Argentina and but they because they need
a cover story to cover the facts that
Argentina is one of those countries that
is part of the American Empire building
that's used by passing bad debt in
getting countries into bad debt
situations this is how America rules
these countries Argentina is a vassal
state of America has been for close to
40 years and they screwed up the
Falkland war you know now there's no
coming back for these folks basically I
don't think now the IMF is lending them
50 billion dollars their largest bailout
ever you know the IMF is basically you
know the Wonga of International Finance
they're a payday lender they should have
been put out of business long ago is
this a good thing that the Wonga of
International Finance the International
Monetary Fund is helping Argentina wolf
well it's not really helping Argentina
it's helping the bondholders you know
the century bond said that you mentioned
their first there they just love the
fact that the IMF is stepping in to help
support that foreign currency debt
that's that's a you know the IMF is the
lender of last resort for countries that
borrow in dollars or in Euros and and
can't and can print away their debts so
yeah the the IMF is the guarantor of
sovereign bonds to bondholders yeah that
Argentina is going to have to
some sacrifices Argentinean people you
know they're going to pay for this
obviously and the purpose is to make
bondholders whole so yeah I'm F
responded on the other the government of
Argentina was asking that IMF to for
this bailout and so that IMF responded
but it's really a bondholder bailout
it's not really a bailout of Argentina
itself but of those bondholders and many
of them are in other countries some of
them are Argentina's themselves that buy
these dollar denominated bonds to to get
the money out of pesos but it spread all
over and a lot of institutional funds
have this pension funds and so forth
that need some yield and those are the
ones that get the benefit from that IMF
bailout I agree with you you know that
I'm after should not exist sovereign
countries should default on the debt and
bondholders should figure out how to how
to take the losses and go on and but
that's not happening we're not we're
trying to create a world where sovereign
bond holders never lose money alright
but you know the IMF lent the money to
begin with now they're buying it back
just like the Federal Reserve lends the
money to begin with then it buys it back
through quantitative easing these are
all accounting tricks by central bankers
and Argentina's had a track record of
the most corrupt worst most evil central
bankers ever in cahoots with Wall Street
banks and the IMF and the World Bank and
all these other central banks and the
problem is always the same yes the
Argentinian people like the Venezuelan
people like the Iranian people like the
Cuban people like all South American
people latin-american people are getting
absolutely shellacked by the machination
of an extraordinarily corrupt central
bank system but the Argentinian people I
don't think they have much of a recourse
I know that according to Oxford
Economics only about 8 million of them
paid taxes last year 21 million were
drawing cash transfers and subsidies can
you comment on that the Argentine
central bank as part of the Ministry of
Finance and has been since the 1930s
when the government nationalized it so
it has been used forever to pay for
political
promises so these handouts you know
Argentina doesn't have the money
it doesn't collect enough taxes so
they're generated by the central bank
that that is part of the Ministry of
Finance and that is what crushes the
currency yeah so this is a political
system that is essentially funded by a
central bank and has been for decades
and it doesn't matter what the shade of
the government is that's how the country
has been set up for the last many
decades and they're continuing to do
this to this day you know that bat
hearts the currency that hearts interest
rates in town in Argentina now 60% 60.0
yeah that is just huge it can
essentially lend money in pesos it just
doesn't work so you have to use another
currency that you can't control and
that's what the central bank has
accomplished and and you know the
central bank is the Minister of Finance
which is the government which changes
shades from time to time but the method
remains the same you make promises you
can't pay for with real money so to
speak and then you create the money to
to fund those projects and then yeah
yeah I'm surprised that even eight
million Argentinians pay taxes I don't
know why the numbers should be anywhere
above zero because all you're doing is
making the problem worse by feeding the
kleptocracy you've got to stop feeding
the crocodile if you want to not get
eaten by the crocodile I know in
Venezuela you know they're they're
turning the crypto currencies to try to
extricate themselves from this type of
nightmare possibly Argentinians I know
our friends over at - are down there on
the ground teaching people about crypto
maybe they can stop 40 years of central
bank corruption finally wolf let me ask
you something many connect the emerging
market currency crisis to the Fed
beginning to unwind quantitative easing
and raise rates so you know the Fed is
doing a little little dance that the
latest episode of their dance of veils
where they pretend to be doing something
worthwhile your thoughts you know
there's a
the broader emerging markets that is
being felt the dollar
barring has become more expensive so
people say there's a shortage of dollars
that's really not the case what there is
is a more expensive dollar so emerging
markets suddenly have to pay more to
lure investors into the markets and that
creates this impression that they're not
enough dollars in in the emerging
markets are plenty of dollars they're
just more expensive and this makes a lot
of these equations a little bit
difficult for the broader emerging
markets but Argentina and tricky those
are unique problems that far exceed any
dollar issue these are when the pace of
plunge is 25 percent in two days that is
unrelated to the dollar the same with
the Turkish lira when the when these
currencies drop in the teens yep from
from few days earlier that's an internal
issue and on the other hand when when
fairly in a well-run emerging markets
have a have an issue with with their own
currency that could be based on the
dollar but in terms of Argentina and
Turkey those issues are a purely country
specific and you mentioned a lot of the
issues in Argentina yeah that is
unrelated to the dollar
well I guess they shouldn't complain too
much that the Argentinian tomfoolery is
makes Americans rich so thank you
Argentina and Venezuela we benefit from
your political mess up anyway wolf
thanks so much being on the Kaiser
report Thank You max okay that's going
to do it for this edition of the Kaiser
report with me Max Keiser and Stacy
Herbert want to thank our guest wolf
Richter of wolf Street dot-com until
next time bye y'all
[Music]